you know how long i've been waiting for
one of you old men to kiss me
he's a good kid
i gotta say out of the four you i think
vito's the best kisser
we just wanted to ask about the internet
gentlemen
are you eating packing peanuts one night
when i was
philandering crystal caught me kissing
jimmy
lynn's heavy breasts why
i'm a human i'm a human male be as moist
no
as juicy as no as wet as you can well
just say
it'll be good man it'll be good man
look how happy he is now
again charles wants to say hi
do you have any milk hmm
now you're a try
big smiles bigger bigger
great now we just have to stay like this
for the next two hours can you feel it
working i don't have any enamel on my
teeth so the cold air is excruciating
maybe if you brushed your teeth once in
a while this wouldn't be a problem i do
brush my teeth
they're decaying from acid reflux you're
embarrassing yourself
you're like you're not australian gina
get stuffed you drongo
guys seriously too much exposure to air
and they will turn to dust
okay okay imagine a letter
had unprotected sex with a phone look
you guys if the sergeant wants to chop
off his penis that is his choice
guess who nypd hands up
my dreams are coming true you and me get
my lady off together
oh put it there pal
god yes queen
we are getting aggravated you look like
millie vanilli ooh i call vanilla
i want a vanilla but you got it he's the
best one you know it's true
looks like you and i are in a good
old-fashioned suck-off
this is ice cream and i'm gonna prove it
sarge
no it's been in their mouths what am i
doing captain holt
what why are you yelling at my boob
because that's where the camera is
nice try ray ray i told you jake
i'll do anything to perk up my little
man this bee needs a c
in her a oh my god
[Applause]
this is taking too long i'm gonna miss
the farmer's market
whatever you need rosa
okay i'll come up with a list we all
have our thing
you're a muscler i'm a boner we call it
giving each other roadhead
did you know there's a sausage you can
drink
because i'm not done with my testicles
yet
i'm gonna let them sing
[Music]
i'm drowning my sorrows in octopus balls
bone
what happens in my bedroom detective is
none of your business
what are these these madame are stds
what are you talking about buddy close
your eyes and open your mouth and a dry
boy
is a smart boy oh
amy when'd you get here you've come for
my
conjugal capabilities you're looking
real good girl oop lost a booby
no matter i'll just build another one
you